Còn hình phố Hàn Nội linh tục tiếp nhận đơn tổ giác từ vui rất bị lời đảo thông qua các ứng dụ như tìt lài, tích tóc, tóc splot.
Thù đảng của các đối tượng là giá dành nhân viên các sản thương mại diện tử, sư thi hoặc thương giữa lớn để nhắn tiền.
Vòa định mời nhận qua tạo, tư đó sủ số nạn nhân thực hiện những vụ online và chuyển tiền nhiều lần vào các tài khoản gân hàng.
Tực tế, đứng sau các đường dây này là các đối tượng người nước ngoài推 người Việt Nam mở tài khoản,
thêm lập công ty để nhận tiền bất hợp pháp.
Sau đó, số tiền được chuyển đổi sáng tiền địa tử, USDT và giúp ra khoa các tài khoản so đối tượng cầm đậu quán lý.
Căn cư chính cư thu thập được, các quan ăn ninh đều tra, công an thình phố Hàn Nội đã hởi tổ vụ an,
khởi tổ bị cân, cảm xác một đối tượng người nước ngoài về tổ dựa tiền.
Bộ công an, khiến cáo người dân từ đối không buồn bán, cho thùy tài khoản gân hàng không chia sẻ thông tin cá nhân với người lạ.
Cảnh giác trước các tin nhắn, cuộc gọi chúng thường và chủ động báo công an khi phát hiện giấu hiệu lừa đạo.
Mọi hình vì tích tay cho tối phạm điều có thể bị sử lý hình sự theo quy định pháp lật.